This parabola would open to the left. Great thinking if you got that one right.
One of the key things to recognize is that this equation is in the form x
equals. Parabolas that are in this form, either open to the left or to the
right. Since the a value is negative 1, we know the parabola will open to the
left. If I had a different parabola like x equals 3y squared, then we can see
that, that parabola opens to the right, since the a value here is positive.
Let's take this one away for a moment and just concentrate on the first
parabola. Again, its vertex is at 0,0. This is the turning point for the
parabola. Notice also that there's an axis of symmetry that goes through the
vertex. It means that if there's a point on this side of the graph, then
directly across from it is another point. For example, we know the point
negative 4,2 is on the graph. So, we could also know that the point negative 4
negative 2 is also on the graph. If we zoom in on our parabola, we can also
find other points by moving from the vertex. Since our parabola's in the form,
x equals. This time, we'll move up and down one unit. Next, we'll move a units
in the x direction to find the two points. So, a is negative 1, so I can go one
unit up and one unit left. This gives me the point negative 1,1. And if I
want to find another point I can move one unit down and one unit left to get
this point negative 1 negative 1. Let's also see this with this graph. x equals
3y squared. If we zoom in on this purple parabola, we can see how to get these
points of three one and 3 negative 1. We start at the vertex and go one unit up
and one unit down, since we're in the form x equals. And this time we're going
to go three units right since the a value is positive 3. So we'll go one unit
up and three units right, one unit down and three units right. This gives us
the other 2 points on our parabola.